how do you overcome it how I overcome it
so I'll cry it out first I'm gonna be
honest I like that I pray I call my God
Mom and I'll call Hallie and my siblings
and I'll just cry and cry and they'll be
like boss up and I'm gonna be honest
when my album came out last week
actually thank you it I never thought
the day would come so when it actually
happened I was like trying to figure out
every way in my head to like make sure
it wasn't happening or like it was like
imposter syndrome so I keep reciting to
myself I deserve it I deserve it I
deserve it I deserve it and I think we
owe it to ourselves we have to give
ourselves flowers before we expect
anybody else to and that's what I'm
learning it's hard but I'm learning